you play a prostitute on the show yeah
and so I'm curious is that a thing an
issue sometimes I do things on this show
and in the old days I don't do it
anymore but I just actually tell my
brother tell my parents not to watch oh
yeah tonight because I would worry about
that is that something when you learned
you me playing a prostitute
are your parents the cool type of
parents were they the more uptight I
would say they're pretty cool I think
well I think mostly they were maybe
worried about me for many years trying
to you know make it as an actor get a
job I think they were just so excited
that I was gonna be on HBO and yeah
having a pretty legitimate like lovely
job so we did the pilot and it was a
lovely experience and then coming up
once we realized this series was picked
up then in the second episode I get a
call from the producers they're like so
you're gonna have to be naked in the
second episode I was like okay
completely naked yeah inside called my
yeah thank you so I called my mom I was
like yo mom I just want to let you know
that the second episode I'm gonna be
naked and she was like full frontal and
I was like yeah she's like oh okay now
say but it's a merkin it's okay it's a
merkin she was like murk and American is
a pubic hair wig okay she I don't know
that
I can hear my mother I swear I could
hear her on the phone writing down oh ok
Merkin and good work tonight yeah yeah
and she's like okay Merc and I gotta
tell the tennis ladies okay Merc and I
think okay so I think somehow that made
it better for her that I'd be naked but
there be a wig yeah a strategically
placed wig okay and you Andy you knew
that word right away I sure did yeah
yeah yeah being the church I belong to
we where I'm so
[Applause]
you